leo está en la búsqueda de huevos de
pascua en su patio donde sus padres
escondieron huevos de plástico los
cuales contienen una moneda de 25
centavos o de 10 centavos en cada uno de
los huevos va a encontrar una moneda ya
sea de 25 centavos o en su dado caso de
10 centavos cuando ha encontrado todos
los huevos ya encontró todos los huevos
escondidos en su jardín cuenta su botín
y descubre que tiene 4 pesos con 80
centavos
escribe la ecuación para representar el
número de monedas de 25 centavos con la
letra q y de 10 centavos con la letra
del que leo ha embolsado ok pues bueno
vamos a escribir aquí la ecuación que
nos piden y para esto lo que quiero que
te des cuenta es que el junto en total 4
pesos con 80 centavos
contando con esto la cantidad de monedas
de 25 centavos que tiene y contando la
cantidad de monedas de 10 centavos que
él tiene y entonces utilizan información
vamos a sacar la primera ecuación y esta
ecuación la voy a escribir de la
siguiente manera primero vamos a
fijarnos en que recuerda que el kun es
la cantidad de monedas de 25 centavos
que ha encontrado leo ahora como cada
una de estas monedas tiene un valor de
25 centavos entonces voy a escribir aquí
0.25
0.25 por q esto me está representando la
cantidad de dinero que va a obtener leo
con las monedas de 25 centavos por
ejemplo si tuviera dos monedas de 25
centavos entonces él tendría 50 centavos
ok pero a esto hay que agregarle a esto
le voy a sumar a y para esto le voy a
sumar aquí a la cantidad de monedas que
se encontró el de 10 centavos que es de
pero también lo voy a multiplicar por su
valor su valor es
0.10 porque son 10 centavos lo que vale
cada una de ellas
este no es un ser perfecto
0.10 x yo estoy poniendo multiplicando
la cantidad de monedas de centavos para
que me dé la cantidad total de dinero
que voy a obtener de las monedas de 10
centavos por ejemplo si leo se encontró
tres monedas de 10 centavos entonces
aquí tendría 30 centavos con estas tres
monedas pero lo que yo sé es que es la
cantidad de dinero que me de las monedas
de 25 centavos más la cantidad de dinero
que me de las monedas de 10 centavos
esto tiene que ser exactamente igual a
una cierta cantidad a lo que se encontró
él en total lo cual es 4 pesos con 80
centavos por lo tanto voy a escribir
aquí
4.80 porque es la cantidad de dinero que
se encontró en total leo ok ya tengo la
ecuación y dice 0.25 q más 0 puntos de
stem esto es igual a 480 ahora vamos a
ver qué me dice en la frase de aquí
abajo si leo ha encontrado 36 web ok
en total encontró 36 huevos y bueno
recuerda que cada uno de los huevos
tiene una moneda de 25 centavos o de 10
centavos cuántos de ellos contienen
monedas de 25 centavos de lujo y esto me
está dando pie a pensar en otra ecuación
así que para esto voy a sacar aquí mi
libreta de apuntes con el pizarrón
electrónico para que así podamos
trabajar la siguiente ecuación ya
habíamos obtenido la primera ecuación la
cual decía que es cero que
0.25 ok esto que multiplica a q ok
hablando de las monedas de 25 centavos y
bueno aquí es tengo representado la
cantidad de dinero que me dan las
monedas de 10 centavos ok si a esto le
agregamos si a esto le agregamos un
0.10 por de que era la cantidad de
monedas de 10 centavos que nosotros
teníamos y bueno aquí justo aquí tenemos
representada la cantidad de dinero que
nos van a dar las monedas de 10 centavos
entonces la suma de estos dos me tenía
que dar
4.84 pesos con 80 centavos o que dedujo
aquí ya tenemos una ecuación la cual
representa la cantidad de dinero total
que obtuvimos de estas monedas de 25
centavos y de 10 centavos
ahora vamos a fijarnos qué es lo que
dice aquí abajo leo ha encontrado 36
huevos eso nos da pie a pensar en otra
ecuación que otra ecuación bueno la
ecuación que va a decir que q que q más
de pumas de an déjame cambiar el color
de de que era justo este esto tiene que
ser exactamente igual a 36 y como puede
obtener esta ecuación bueno pues es que
date cuenta que tenemos solamente 36
huevos y cada uno de esos huevos tiene
una moneda de 25 centavos o una moneda
de 10 centavos por cada huevo hay una
moneda por lo tanto tenemos 36 monedas
36 monedas de las cuales algunas son de
25 centavos y otras de 10 ahora como
nosotros sabemos hay varios métodos para
resolver este tipo de sistemas de
ecuaciones porque date cuenta tenemos
dos ecuaciones con dos incógnitas dos
ecuaciones lineales y bueno tenemos por
ejemplo el método de sustitución o bueno
también tenemos el método de suma y
resta si nosotros escalamos una de esas
dos ecuaciones multiplicando la por una
constante para que se puedan eliminar o
bueno hay muchos métodos más pero en
esta ocasión quiero ver el método de
sustitución por el método de sustitución
vamos a resolver este problema así que
de esta ecuación de la ecuación de aquí
abajo déjame despejar aquí
y bueno si yo resto de ambos lados de
esta ecuación voy a obtener que q q es
exactamente lo mismo que 36 que 36
a esto le voy a quitar de del lujo y
entonces si sustituyó aquí en esta
ecuación ya voy a encontrar una ecuación
que solamente depende de de y de hecho
me va a quedar lo siguiente me va a
quedar
0.25 que multiplica a q o pero nosotros
sabemos que cuba le 36 menos d
voy a sustituir el valor de q justo aquí
y entonces me va a quedar a 0.25 que
multiplica a 36 a 36 menos menos de ok
36 menos de y a esto le sumamos a
0.10 de esto tiene que ser igual a
480 déjame ponerlo con su respectivo
color a
480 ok y date cuenta que con esto vamos
a obtener el valor de de y después vamos
a obtener el valor de las monedas de
veinticinco centavos
bueno bueno tal vez una manera más
directa tú podrás obtener este valor que
nosotros buscamos el de las monedas de
25 centavos si de esta ecuación
hubiésemos despejado a dent pero bueno
ya despejamos aquí y entonces vamos a
trabajar con esta ecuación de aquí y que
me va a quedar bueno pues tengo 0.25 por
36 bueno esto es lo mismo que 36 por un
cuarto o dividir 36 entre 4 lo cual es
lo mismo que
99 - 0.25 x de lo cual es 0.25 de
0.25 ok esto que multiplica a de ok ya
esto le voy a sumar a esto lo voy a
sumar
0.10 de ok y esto tiene que ser igual a
4.80 a
4.80 ahora lo que quiero es obtener el
valor de de positivo por lo tanto voy a
pasar este 0.25 de del otro lado este 10
de del otro lado y éste 4.80 lo voy a
pasar de este lado de tal manera que me
va a quedar lo siguiente aquí voy a este
es menos aquí voy a sumar
1.25 de ok aquí voy a restar voy a
restar
0.10 de ok y de este lado derecho de la
ecuación lo que voy a hacer es primero
sumar voy a sumar
0.25 de ok ya esto le voy a restar
0.10 de lo que haga de un lado lo voy a
hacer exactamente igual del otro ok y
ahora éste 4.80 lo voy a pasar de este
lado y lo voy a pasar de este lado con
signo contrario de tal manera que de
este lado me va a quedar menos
4.8 y de ese lado también menos
4.8 ok de tal manera que ahora si estos
dos se van a cancelar estos dos se van a
cancelar y del lado izquierdo solamente
me va a quedar
99 menos 4.8 lo cual es lo mismo que 4.2
aquí me queda 4.2 esto es exactamente
igual que y bueno de este lado esto se
van a cancelar ok y estos se pueden
reducir a 0.25 de menos 0 puntos días de
esto es lo mismo que
0.15
ok de lujo pero esto esto me va a
implicar una operación que tengan que
ver con decimales así que lo mejor es
pasar esto a fracción se me ocurre pasar
el 0.15 a fracción y bueno 0.15 nosotros
sabemos que es lo mismo que han piense
sobre 100 ok ya esto lo puedo sacar
quinta esto es exactamente lo mismo que
3 entre un 20 3 entre 20 y yo le sacó
quinta y entonces esta expresión de aquí
me va a quedar de la siguiente manera
esto es lo mismo que 3 sobre 20 que
multiplica a adén esto es igual a 4.2
pero 4.2 también lo voy a escribir como
una fracción 4.2 4.2 es lo mismo que 42
sobre 10 ok y esto es lo mismo que si
saco mitad arriba en mi trabajo me queda
21 sobre 5 ok escribir así 21
5 ok entonces llegó a esta ecuación de
aquí que le voy a escribir justo acá
abajo esto lo mismo que 3 sobre 20 que
multiplica de esto es igual a 21 entre 5
y 21 entre 5 pero como quiero obtener el
valor de d entonces voy a multiplicar
por el recíproco es decir voy a
multiplicar aquí por 20 entre 3 y aquí
voy a multiplicar por 20 entre 3 ok
vamos a multiplicar de tal manera que
estos se van este este este y éste se va
y solamente me queda que de d es igual a
21 entre 3 21 entre 3 lo cual es 7 si
reduzco este con este me queda 7 y aquí
lo voy a multiplicar por 20 entre 520 y
35 es lo mismo que 47 por 4 es 28 ok del
lujo la cantidad de monedas de 10
centavos eran 28 pero yo lo que quiero
saber es la cantidad de monedas de 25
centavos por lo tanto yo sé que q es
igual a 36 - usted me ha dicho otra
manera para obtener valor de q lo que
tengo que hacer es tomarme 36 28 am lo
voy a poner así 36 28 y entonces me va a
dar que 36 menos 28 es 8 q es igual
ahora tenemos ocho monedas de 25
centavos y por lo tanto vamos a
escribirlo justo aquí en mi opción
88 es la cantidad de monedas que tengo
de 25 centavos y de lujo estamos bien